do you also categorize it to them as
like you should be embarrassed by this
do you have them sit with that or like
how do you approach telling another
human they should be embarrassed is very
disrespectful there's accountability but
we're not playing well and to me I'm not
you can't run from that we should all
know that we we we did not play well
tonight you know what I mean like that's
a
[Music]
fact your reaction to What Joe moula
just said I did well you know we live in
different times but I I disagree with
that because when you're big built for a
championship and you're playing like you
want to win the championship everything
has to fall in place me and Chuck argued
about this all the time can't turn that
switch on and it's better to not have
the switch down to where you have to
come back up always have to switch up
every now and in certain circumstan
switch can go down you could switch it
back up but they're supposed to blow
this team out you ever had a coach tell
you you should be embarrassed oh all the
time uh Phil Jackson and Dale Brown and
Coach Dave madora all the time and you
know back in my era that that that that
was used as you know motivation yes it's
very disrespectful as a human but you
know sometimes you know the truth hurts
and you know I'm going just blame it on
one of those games but Chuck said it
can't disrespect your opponent the
Lakers look really good because you know
most of the time with LeBron and AD you
got two guys handling the ball the
highlights you showed everybody was
touching the ball when you're NBA player
and you get the opportunity to touch the
ball you play at a high level so they
came out smoking Boston never reacted so
so they just kept playing you let a guy
like Reeves get into a rhythm he can
kill you he goes back to back season
highs Celtic should be Celtics should be
embarrassed you should never lose to
this team without LeBron and AD so maybe
it's something you don't need to say but
that's something that they feel no no
you need to say it Arnie uh you have to
you have to I told you I'm really
concerned about the Celtics not just
tonight this is three games in a row
they were 20 and0 at home they've lost
three in a row at home no but they're 22
and two well they lost they've lost
three games in a row three out of five
three out of five to the best team this
team was not a good one but the teams
that they going to play if they get to
the finals in my opinion you you have to
be ready for those games like Shaq and
Kenny know this every game's not the
same you're like oh the Denver Nuggets
are coming to town we need to send them
a message Denver came in there and beat
him then the Clippers came out and beat
them the two teams in the west that like
we have to play in the finals it tells
me that they just playing on Talent
they're not mentally tough enough like
no man this is a big game we need to be
ready
anytime I played against Michael magic
bird caralon Patrick y it was a
different game cuz it's you call it ego
whatever you want to call it but when
you on a good team and you're like okay
we might play these guys you got to get
read mentally and to me the Celtics a
winning game on Talent you know what
they remind me of my Philadelphia Eagles
H like there that's something just
happened in the NBA even though
Milwaukee had that second best record
they said we're not going to win the
championship we got to make a change the
Celtics to me they got a really good
record but they're not going to win the
championship let me let me ask you this
and and and I'll need camera one here
because this is on December 4th uh what
you said and what and what we wrote down
you were convinced the Celtics will win
the Championships you said that in
December and I know earlier tonight you
said Tatum and brown are great but
they're too nice they were nice guys
when you said this but and they're still
nice guys but now why can't they win
because if you go if you as to go back
and look they showed us stat they're
always behind they're always behind but
you're saying now they're not going to
win the championship I don't think they
er I don't like what I'm seeing right I
I I still think first of all there's no
team in the NBA that's better at the
Celtics but you have to be mentally
tough cuz you like you can't turn it on
and off off you you because you develop
too many bad habits they're developing
bad habits you have been patiently
waiting oh yeah these are Hall of Famers
these are guys who've done it at the
highest level they've LED teams not just
been part of teams so I'm listening but
there is a part of me that understands
there is a level of mental exhaustion
just like his mental for fortitude so
there is mental exhaustion when you do
have the best record which they do in
the NBA there's no other team in the NBA
has a better record than the Boston
Celtics at times there will be a portion
of that season where you have a little
bit of mental exhaustion now to me and a
lot of times that happens two weeks
before the All-Star Game 100 there you
go it happen but how it stops is a game
like this it's the wake up it's like yo
wait wait wait we we've hit the low we
gotta like we've hit it we can't talk
about minimal exhaustion anymore we've
got to turn it on and keep it on now but
what about big games Kenny be because
big games you think about
it the game sometime even though the
this is just my opinion even though the
Denver Nuggets are the NBA champions the
Boston Celtics is a more F story
franchise so meaning it's a bigger game
sometime for your opponent so they play
well they're coming in going with the
same
mentality you think Denver going in
there saying we got to go beat them go
ahead cuz one they are the former chubs
and and the joke ain't no Chum joke is a
great player so when great players going
against a great player like Chuck said
so it's not a shame to lose to them it's
not embarrassing to lose to them no no
but you're not supposed to L if you have
that Championship mentality I don't care
who's coming out you got to beat them
and play well you know they they lost
convincingly lost but but you shows us
they
ready I just feel I I just mean I just
feel that at certain points what chose
me if if you're a champion is when you
turn the volume off and like no we're
going to kill this noise now and this is
a noise killing game that's what that I
would say this is the noise now we see
where they go from here yeah kudos to
the Lakers on this one 114 105 winners
over the Boston Celtics as they snap
their two game losing streak and the
Celtics have their two- game winning
streak snap uh looking like a Dixie
cup like a Dixie cup that's actually
kind of fly to your mama she wants some
oh